the title of this is Klaus Schwab the
most dangerous man in the world let's
add a stream here if you guys can't hear
me or hear the playback in the um live
chat
um just let me know and for those of you
that are listening to the replay because
these podcasts by the way they're also
in Spotify and apple and all sort of
stuff and uh SoundCloud
um just a fair warning I've got this at
1.75 speed so if you're already
listening at 1.75 speed it's going to
sound pretty crazy so slow down your
playback speed right now but listen up
here TWA breaks the following one of the
greatest lessons of the past five
centuries in Europe and America is this
acute crisis contribute to boosting the
power of the state it's always been the
case and there is no reason why it
should be different with a pandemic so
and I've got to pause this from time to
time just um you know for YouTube issues
just to comment on it but
um never let a good crisis go to waste
is basically you know the uh
distillation of what he's getting out
over there it's uh it's it's been done
that way throughout history
um people that
actually let me summarize it this way
human beings love being ruled okay I've
said this several times before it's
obvious to me now I don't know if it's
obvious to you guys yet
um if you haven't noticed since 2019 up
until very recently
um you've been lied to you know and uh
manufactured indignation right they said
there was a pandemic coming and bad [ __ ]
was going to happen and we ought to all
you know tow the line and stand on dots
and wear masks and stay inside and all
that stuff
um last time I checked when I looked up
what the definition of pandemic was it's
when a crisis affects the world
people die a lot of people die in fact
and uh it had a survival rate like over
99.9 percent
so
don't think it was a pandemic but they
tried
um anyway let's continue playing this
over here because I want to talk about
the lies after I'm done through this
clip nobody ever likely culture out to
anything this all just sounds like
conspiracy doesn't it the world economic
Forum are good guys haven't you seen the
headlines they pay for go green right
I want to talk about that go green thing
because I wish I had some tinfoil in my
house because I don't have any I was I
was looking for some so I could make a
tinfoil hat whenever I needed to talk
about something that um
might need to be understood from that
perspective
um the whole go green thing is it's nice
and it sells well and um
it's
um it's got traction you know there's no
question that climate changes throughout
history
um I'm pretty sure human beings have an
influence on that I mean there's no
question about it I mean you know when
you dig up uh carbon from the ground and
you combust it and you put it back in
the atmosphere
um in large quantities it's it's going
to contribute some change out there but
with you know what I don't want to give
away the full summary yet because I
because I kind of want to deal with that
towards the end when I deal with the
solutions and what I think is happening
with that flow but yeah
the whole green movement
you know seems all nice warm and fuzzy
because you want to save the baby seals
and the polar bears and stuff like that
um but there's some other stuff going on
behind the scenes which I'll get to in a
little bit after we're done this clip
here right that's probably right they
truly are good guys accordingly you'll
be excited to hear that the lineup of
world economic Forum speakers at their
annual Gathering of Elites and Davos
included such benevolent humanitarians
like ji jinpin the leader of the Chinese
Communist Party who's currently
committing genocide Anthony who's
arguably currently involved in crimes
against humanity and Bill Gates who's
arguably currently involved in crimes
against humanity and I
um I saw this Ted Talk
um that Bill Gates gave and a few other
subsequent videos that were recommended
to me after I watched it where he was
talking about
um a pandemic coming this was around
2014 to 2016 and it would be a SARS kovi
type of
um pandemic right
um I I don't think it's a coincidence
that he was talking about it during that
time and I don't think it's a
coincidence that he was so heavily
involved in um
The Narrative around uh what fauci was
talking about and also the fact that
um you know vaccinations
um were going to play a very big role in
how he profited from it too as well
let's keep going through this guy's clip
here Australian prime minister Scott
Morrison who's arguably currently
involved in crimes against humanity what
a great lineup about my favorite
economic Forum speaker of all time is
this reptile how's Schwab's top advisor
Dr Yuval Noah Harari let's see what he
has to say Knight enable now um
I don't think he he mentions it here but
Noah Yuval Harari is the author of the
book sapience which I actually have
pinned Below on all my videos on my
Amazon recommended reading list uh he
also wrote a follow-up book which is
called homoduous
um sapiens is basically a brief uh like
history of humankinds as we've operated
as sapiens now we've moved around the
earth and what effect we've had on the
earth and all that stuff and I thought
it was a relatively good book
um you know it essentially concluded
that the reason why Society is the way
that it is today
um and it mentioned liberalism a lot
towards the end and it also talked a lot
about how uh Gossip was essentially what
made us unbeatable on you know the
planet and made us a dominant species
but um in his follow-up book he also
talks about
um Ai and what sort of future he
foresees the way liberalism is taking
things
um I didn't know this dude was a
consultant to Klaus Schwab in the world
economic Forum until I started uh
consuming a lot more of the content
uh what does it say at the top there it
says Dr Yuval Noah Harari is a
transhumanist and top advisor to Klaus
Schwab and the world economic Forum so
let's hear what this guy has to say
about stuff here
human Elite to do something even more
radical than just build digital
dictatorships by hacking organisms
Elites May gain the power to re-engineer
the future of life itself because once
you can hack something you can usually
also engineer it Elites hacking
organisms and re-engineering life itself
well he's not talking about doing that
to people is he now in the past
he's not talking about doing that sure
he's not talking about doing it to
lizards is he
what does it say that thought they're Dr
Norview okay so I mean Pirates and
government
talking about hacking people like what
is this guy on about now oh no the KGB
could do it but
I guess he was talking about doing that
to people all people to be specific and
if indeed we succeed in hacking and
Engineering life this will be not just
the greater so if you guys have been
asleep the last decade or so
um information is the most valuable
currency to
Elites you know people that run these
large companies uh large governments or
non-profit organizations like World
economic Forum by the way that's a
non-profit organization and they have a
membership and it wasn't clear what the
membership was on the low end
um they mentioned sixty seven thousand
dollars and on the high end
um one uh piece of content that I came
across is 627
000 so it's unclear what it costs to
become a member and contribute and to
influence the ideology but it's not
cheap for most people I mean
I mean sixty thousand dollars you're
going to get a lot more people in I
suspect it's probably in the 100th in
the in the six figure range let me just
quickly have a quick look at the super
chats here dude is Desi says down with a
great rest every second I get an amen
um have you heard Elon Musk talking
about robots making human labor a thing
of the past and Universal basic income
for all the future yeah that's that's
where things are potentially going
um foreign
Universal basic income is you know for
those that are unclear is basically the
the state giving you
um I'm just going to call it money you
know for the time being it's a
placeholder term but you know we'll call
it money because you can buy [ __ ] with
money
um but the government's going to give
you money where um you'll be able to
take a you know take care of your living
expenses and things like robots or AI
will take care of most menial tasks like
you know when your grandfather or great
grandfather came back from the war in
World War II and uh started working in a
factory maybe screwing
uh caps on toothpaste tubes or something
like that and you know you could have a
family in a house and a white picket
fence and all that sort of stuff and you
come home and your wife would kiss you
on the cheek like Leave it to Beaver
um yeah those days are certainly not
going to be around anymore it like with
AI and with robots a lot of things will
be automated and
um you'll end up basically just getting
money from the state
um to take care of your basic needs but
it's unclear how much of the basic needs
will be taken care of
um and what
you know things that they're going to
automate with robotics and AI
um but there's certainly a lot more
people than what we need in the labor
force right now we don't with robots in
in AI you don't need much of a labor
force you know for being honest
um I'll get to these super chats in a
minute let me just keep playing this
revolution in the history of humanity
this will be the greatest revolution in
biology since the very beginning of Life
4 billion years ago for four billion
years nothing fundamental change not
playing bad are you because that usually
works out super well science is with
lazy evolution by natural selection with
evolution by intelligent design not the
intelligent design of some God above the
clouds oh you are playing God say more
playing God eh some God above the clouds
I need to stand up for this this is this
is this is going to get intense
okay play evolution by natural selection
with evolution intelligent design not
the intelligent design of some God above
the clouds but our intelligent design
and the intelligence this guy is not
fond of religion by the way he he you
know he talks mostly about stuff
um tied into the scientific Community
most guys in the scientific Community
are uh atheists of course
um but he's kind of a post that he talks
a lot about like uh gays and stuff like
that and a lot of the content that I
came across too the design of our clouds
the end cloud in Microsoft cloud these
are the new driving forces of evolution
gosh even my changes have a plan in
place on how to control people with your
Cloud technology would you and that plan
isn't by chance already being
implemented today we have the technology
to hack human beings on a massive scale
how many times has this guy said this
now we can hack human beings on a
massive scale I mean they're already
tracking all of your data you don't have
privacy we haven't had privacy for quite
a long time basically ever since we've
had these handheld devices uh Google
home uh speakers that you talk to
um Alexa's if you think that they're not
listening all the time like if you think
they're only listening when you go hey
Google or hey Alexa
um you're not awake dude like you're
like you're plugged in there's a reason
why I don't have one of those [ __ ]
things in my house oh so you could
implement it in this time of Crisis you
have to follow science it's often said
that you should never allow a good
crisis to go to waste sounds familiar
and I guess you are implementing it
already we've heard
I don't know probably at least four or
five like significant world leaders
regurgitate that term Justin Trudeau
said it like dozens of times over the
last year it's it's you know
um this guy not to say any of this out
loud on camera it's it's just it's a lot
of evidence it's surveillance people
could look back in 100 years and
identify the coronavirus epidemic as the
moment when a new regime of surveillance
took over especially surveillance Under
the Skin So yes look there's guys that
are going to argue you're really gonna
surveille you Richard [ __ ] dude yeah
okay what's what's happened you know
like over the last couple years we've
had concentration camps built in several
countries
uh they've they force you to download an
app here in Canada if you want to travel
federally so the provincial governments
have have been a little more
on the side of the people whereas the
federal government's been more on the
side of
um
totalitarianism sort of thing so if you
want to travel you have to have this app
on your phone apparently like even when
the app's on your phone and you approach
the Border you don't even have to show
them you know the barcode or the app
they just know that it's you because
they're tracking your device
um surveillance has been going on for a
long time you don't have privacy
um you have
probably 90 percent less privacy than
what most people think most people that
are plugged into their sleepwalking
through life if I can put it that way my
brain my body my life doesn't belong to
me also some Corporation also the
government
Collective this guy's revealing all plan
he's gonna ruin it the world economic
Forum out for the good of humanity
you'll own nothing not even your own DNA
if we have our way now through some
additional fun facts about clouds so
I don't know if you guys recall but the
you know the vaccine that was created
was mRNA and we've seen um Dr McCullough
and um a few others speak about the
nature of it
um they're already hacking human beings
right
um in this case you know the argument
was well this will make the vaccine more
effective and work faster and blah blah
blah but again
all I see is lies you know all I'm doing
is I'm just pointing to the fact we
didn't have a global pandemic there was
no mass extinction
um the lockdowns didn't work the mass
don't work you know we know that the
virus particle is smaller than what the
mass can filter
um the vaccination did not deliver as
his promise you know stopping
transmission and stopping you from
getting it most people that get it most
people that transmit are vaccinated so
there's no like logical reason why you
should have a QR code on your phone if
you want to travel out of a Canadian
Airport today
but most people do it I mean most people
are under surveillance
and the world economic Forum they've got
a young leaders program which is a
five-year indoctrination program into
their principles the goal of the program
is to create world leaders who I love
how he calls it an indoctrination
program which essentially is what it is
don't answer to their people because
they don't care about the answer to the
bosses of the world that come on Forum
graduates of the program include
admirable world leaders that are
suspiciously unlocked up with a great
reset such as Justin Trudeau Francis
macron and Mark Zuckerberg sponsoring
partners of the world economic forums a
young Global also the leader of
Australia New Zealand uh I think Boris
Johnson it seems like the US is
reasonably resilient to this which is a
good thing for Americans they're also
the most armed country in the world too
aside from Switzerland if I'm not
mistaken but um you know we already know
that Joe Biden's a puppet like he's
he's not there you know it's like we
used to joke back in the day we'd say
you know if somebody was stupid we'd say
look you know the motor's running but
nobody's behind the wheel sort of thing
that's what you got with Joe Biden right
like he has handlers so you know he's
just a placeholder for the people that
don't want to be in front of the camera
but are basically pulling the strings if
you know what I'm saying so they don't
seem to be subscribing to the WF us wef
stuff Hook Line and Sinker like macron
Trudeau and you know a few of the other
world leaders as well right now but
let's keep going leaders program have
been the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation and Google I wonder why
Google censors and shapes information to
be an exact support of the world like an
uniforms narrative oh another fun fact
the world economic forum is predicting a
worldwide Cyber attack I'm pretty much
what they're gonna predict okay
predicting a worldwide Cyber attack so
let's just think for a second
what country is known to have phenomenal
hackers
Russia where is there a conflict going
on in the world right now
on the border between Russia and Ukraine
it's it's entirely feasible that
something like this could come out of it
Hey listen just fair warning that's the
whole tinfoil hat thing that I wanted to
sort of like have handy maybe I'll have
to get one for you guys you know if I
keep doing stuff like this but let's
keep going
the very concerned Schwab believes the
Cyber attack could bring a complete halt
to our power grid Transportation
Hospital Services into our society as a
whole the world economic Forum then
simulated the Cyber attack simulator
plan I'm not sure but they said it was a
simulation so it's probably best to just
believe them oh also the world economic
Forum along with Bill no one against
Foundation hosted event 201 which oddly
enough played out exactly as they
planned or simulated or whatever let's
move on and here's a picture of class
Schwab sitting in front of the Statue of
Vladimir Lenin I wonder why he's got a
statue of one of the most murderous
world leaders in history on and killed
in estimated five million people and
finally remember Schwab's whole thing
about you'll owe nothing and be happy
about it look at this dork over here
they just find stock photography and
slap some slogan slogan on it that I'm
sure a large part of the population
thinks is a pretty cool idea
um yeah it's you know it's just insane
how classification of the West is all
consuming what's the world economic
forums plan to make that happen well
it's probably nothing but consider this
Block rock is an investment firm with
nine trillion dollars under management
which is a higher GDP than every country
on Earth before it turns out BlackRock
has more political and financial
influence than the Federal Reserve and
most governments sounds cool but what's
the connection with a world economic
Forum well again and it's probably
nothing but BlackRock CEO Larry Fink is
also just a board member of the world
economic
let me just pause for a second get a
super chat here just take a break from
the playback
um
F22 Daniel what bothers me about
Orwell's 1984 is that he writes about
all the problems regarding
authoritarianism but provides no
Solutions whatsoever I will provide you
with Solutions today stay stay to the
end I am I am known for providing
Solutions
so tight Brothers I got you covered hey
Rich you should read the book the next
million years how to kill off excess
population by Charles G jarwin it's
public domain you can read it for free
all right
well it's super convenient it probably
doesn't coincidence is the world
economic form and BlackRock colluding
and corporatism where an unelected
corporate dictates top down to the
population well they couldn't be doing
that because they'd have to infiltrate
the government which they haven't done
except for in one of Joe Biden's first
appointees once he took office he named
Brian Beast to be the Director of
National Economic Council Randy's came
from BlackRock so
okay
yeah we're yeah we're starting to
connect some dots or let's keep going it
was a global head of sustainable
investing and now he's Biden's main
advisor for economic policy but by who's
making the policy decisions not the
unelected corporate Elites at Blackrock
in the world economic Forum of course
fighting is making all the decisions
let's not be silly but look there's a
picture of binding audience at the world
like in my Forum oh and also Kamala
Harris's chief economic advisor is
Michael Pyle
he came from BlackRock where he was a
global Chief economics hmm
are you guys starting to see a pattern
here kind of just overseen the strategy
for investing nine trillion dollars well
it looks like corporatism but it's
probably not but if it was it would
actually be a Bible strategy for
BlackRock and World economic Forum to
own everything and for you to own
nothing oh fun fact BlackRock is buying
up single family homes at an alarming
rate oftentimes so at no time in history
has a institution bought up
single-family homes at the rate that
BlackRock is right now by the way he
doesn't clarify that but there is a
bunch of other content that I came
across that detailed it I think 20 to 50
above asking price and they're
overpaying for the for the real estate
too 20 to 50 Higher by the way so normal
people like you and I can't own homes no
there is an interesting pattern to call
this you know how you hear about ancient
tyrannical rulers who would rule over
their dumb people by saying things like
yeah if you don't do all of this slave
labor and let me sleep well here wise
then God's Gonna Make You All perish in
a deadly storm well God told me and
because I'm Elite I have access to this
knowledge and you don't so you better do
as I say or you're gonna die well us
peasants can't perceive what the king
can so we better do as he says again
right people love being ruled it's it's
that's that's what humans like they like
a ruler they love it they love it
that's why when they said oh we got to
lock you down you got to wear these
masks and stand on dots like you know
people love standing on their dots man
go ahead and beg my wife and thank you
for doing that for my protection gang
good old fear-mongering a predictable
pattern as old as time itself oh with
clouds in the world economic Forum it's
climate change is going to kill you
disease is going to kill you and it's
cyber attacks Gonna Get You better do as
we say let's just recap
climate chains disease and cyber attacks
all things that you really can't
pinpoint a source on just remember that
you know because there's a reason why
covet originated from China
communist country where are you going to
get the source data from they're going
to hide it from you that's different
with a democratic country even then
they're still going to try to hide it we
still don't know anything about this
Hunter Biden laptop situation of course
but you know
China was convenient for sure it dude
like that was not a bat banging a snake
that's not where it came from
you're gonna die hello well it looks
pretty good to me why don't you ever
smile clouds look like a sociopath no if
you don't understand we at least have
access to knowledge that you don't so
you better listen to us or you're gonna
die same old fun pattern if you're on
green they know what they're scary
problems and only they have the
solutions so listen up if you're gonna
die
not too close nothing new here I like
this guy he's like he's he's solid man
like he's funny we see you in conclusion
to the question is Klaus Schwab the most
dangerous man in the world here's his
top guy again humans I'm now hackable
animals you know the whole idea that
humans have you know this they have this
Soul spirit and they have free will and
nobody knows what's happening inside me
so whatever I choose whether in the
election or whether in the supermarket
This Is My Free Will that's over
Free Will is over
let that like like marinate on that for
a bit right your free will as far as
these guys are concerned is over
I remember when Free Will was a cool
thing oh I can't wait till I'm an adult
so I can get a driver's license to drive
a car and go where I want sort of thing
can't wait till I'm an adult and I make
some money so I can travel and go where
I want I've been able to do that for
like three years in Canada will indeed
be over if you Outsource your thinking
to outside influences and take the easy
way out by choosing obedience over
Gregory doing so it makes you very
susceptible to being manipulated by fear
and if this happens you will fail at
remaining a free sovereign individual
but here's how Schwab and his friends
who sociopathically never smile fail at
the great reset and you succeed at
remaining so he's offering a solution
he's basically saying choosing bravery
over obedience I'm going to talk more
about that and I think it ties more to
sovereignty if I'm being honest a free
sovereign individual be guided by your
own critical thinking and what your
heart and soul knows is right and choose
bravery over obedience obedience or
bravery Outsource your perspectives or
do your own critical thinking we are in
the process of either the great reset or
the Great Awakening all right so that's
so that's that for that he just kind of
uh
drones on for a little bit and then
doesn't add
um
let me see here what do we got super
chats Leo
varadakar former prime minister of
Ireland
does it sound like a very Irish name
it's a member of the world economic
Forum last year the Irish and the South
fled to Northern Ireland because
Northern Ireland had no coveted
passports
um
there's a lot of people that have moved
around the world as a result of this
pandemic lockdown stuff I have several
friends that no longer live in Canada
because at one point they were like you
know what I don't like the tax rate but
I have family here and I've been here
most of my life so I'm just gonna do it
whatever hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out